[Musica]
sapete dirmi quando cadrà il prossimo
asteroidi killer ovvero quella strada in
grado di uccidere in un colpo solo
almeno il 25 per cento degli esseri
viventi
vi posso dire che quasi sicuramente
accadrà nei prossimi 100 milioni di anni
problema che non so dirvi se accadrà fra
dieci anni o fra 99 milioni di anni
questa sera vi parlerà appunto di
asteroidi gli asteroidi che possono
chiedere con la terra è quello che sta
facendo la comunità scientifica in
questo argomento però prima vi vorrei
parlare un po degli asteroidi e vorrei
introdurvi cosa sono e rispondere a tre
particolari domani quindi chi sono
perché esistono e da dove vengono
allora innanzitutto chi sono sono ci
possono essere diversi tipi di asteroidi
io ho prenotato di modellini esempio
potete avere un asteroide di tipo
metallico formato soprattutto da nichel
e ferro quindi molto denso molto pesante
e alla caratteristica anche di essere
molto riflettente riflette come uno
specchio la luce del sole e attenzione
alterò ed in aria secondo tipo di
asteroidi tipo roccioso stone in inglese
composto da silicati e altri minerali un
pochino meno denso pochino più scuro
però che questo vocale vita
terzo tipo di asteroidi sono quelli
carbonacee al carbonai ci sono quelli
più numerosi sono ovviamente dal nome
sono composti soprattutto dal carbonio
ed altri minerali sono molto più leggere
alcuni potrebbero addirittura a
galleggiare sull'acqua e sono molto
scuri riflettono solo il 34 per cento
della luce del sole però che questi ops
sbagliato dunque lo farò mai lanciatore
di baseball bene però mi sono
dimenticato di una cosa ci sono anche le
comete vero come sono fatte le comete
prendiamo l'asteroide carbonaceo
aggiungiamo un po di acqua c'è giusto
crimaldi leverone non mettiamo nel
freezer e otteniamo qualcosa molto
simile a una cometa attenzione che
questa che anche la scia
va bene essere più o meno cosa sono gli
asteroidi e le comete
adesso però vi dico perché esistono
allora gli asteroidi in realtà non sono
altro che dei fossili nel nostro sistema
solare
allora forse perché provengono dai dei
planetesimi primordiali che non sono
stati in grado di formare un pianeta più
massiccio come la terra dove si trovano
alla gran parte degli asteroidi
conosciuti si trovano in una fascia a
chiamata appunto fascia degli asteroidi
che si trova tra marte e giove infatti
giove perché è molto massiccio non ha
permesso a questi planetesimi
primordiali proprio di aggregarsi in
realtà poi ci sono tanti asteroidi oltre
l'orbita di nettuno si chiama trans
nettuniani e questi sono effettivamente
gli oggetti più primordiali del nostro
sistema solare
in realtà poi ci sono oggetti che
passano dall uno all altra regione ci
sono i centauri che passano punto delle
trans nettuniani alla fascia interna
fascia degli asteroidi ma alcuni di essi
riescono addirittura a penetrare il
sistema solare ea entrare verso il sole
e quindi passare dc
nella terra possono intercettare
l'orbita della terra
ecco il problema allora è mai capitato
ci siano stati impatti di asteroidi
sulla sulla terra allora basta guardare
la luna ci accorgiamo di una cosa la
luna è tutta butterata di crateri da
impatto sono il risultato di impatto di
asteroidi avvenuti miliardi di anni che
sono rimasti lì sulla terra non li
troviamo tutte queste tracce di impatti
di asteroidi perché perché la terra non
vantaggio è un pianeta vivo non vivo
solo perché ci sono degli esseri viventi
ma il video perché è geologicamente vivo
c'è tettonica a zolle c'è l'atmosfera
venti la pioggia e questi rimarginano le
ferite causate dagli impatti di
asteroidi
tuttavia possiamo trovare delle ferite
quelle più profonde che rimangono
ci sono alcune tracce qui vediamo per
esempio il mezzo crafter che un cratere
famoso perché si trova in arizona
causato da un oggetto di ferro nichel
appunto che è caduto 50.000 anni fa ha
causato un impatto di fratel e di un
chilometro e mezzo ed era solo 50 metri
in diametro
recentemente poi qualche anno fa è stato
scoperto un cratere di 180 km di
diametro si trova in uno yucatan che la
penisola messicana e questo è stato
datato a 66 milioni di anni fa è stato
probabilmente un oggetto di 12 km
dimensione e la cosa interessante che
proprio 66 milioni di anni fa c'è stata
l'estinzione di massa dei dinosauri e ci
sono diverse prove che ci indicano che
l'estinzione è stata causata proprio da
questo tipo di asteroidi
in realtà questi eventi catastrofici che
coinvolgono tutto il pianeta sono molto
molto rari tuttavia ci sono oggetti più
piccoli che possono cadere molto
frequentemente per esempio un evento
abbastanza noto quello di che è avvenuto
nel 1908 poco più di un secolo fa in una
regione della siberia schema
brusca c'è stato un oggetto di una
settantina di metri che è esploso in
volo ea l'onda d'urto ha causato la
distruzione di 2.200 chilometri quadrati
di foresta 2.200 chilometri quadrati è
l'area tipica di una città metropolitana
come roma potete immaginare cosa poteva
aver causato se cadesse avesse fosse
caduta in una città popolata
recentemente poi ammiriamo un po i tempi
nostri
nel 2013 un altro oggetto sempre in
russia non sono sfortunati questo è un
oggetto di 15 18 metri quindi poco più
di un autobus
ecco è esploso a 30 chilometri d'altezza
sopra la città di celiabinsk anche lì
l'onda d'urto arrivata al suolo e ha
distrutto migliaia di metri quadri di
vetri e quindi purtroppo ha ferito un
migliaio circa di persone tra cui 200
bambini quindi la morale è il pericolo
c'è esiste e bisogna fare qualcosa
allora cosa vogliamo fare bisogna
scoprire questi oggetti il prima
possibile
se noi li scopriamo e sappiamo che sono
i wrote e collisioni cosa possiamo fare
possiamo deflettere lo possiamo
distruggerlo
oppure se è piccolo e lo veniamo sapere
che impatterà di qui a poco tempo
possiamo calcolare il luogo di impatto e
quindi evacuare e quindi mettere in
sicurezza le cose le persone però
bisogna appunto scoprirli questi oggetti
allora sin dagli anni 90 d'america gli
stati uniti hanno investito forti
risorse per scoprire gli asteroidi
killer servono dei telescopi particolari
telescopio grande campo ovvero in grado
di osservare una fetta di cielo molto
grande in pochissimo tempo
questo modo diciamo fanno da sentinella
e scoprono tutti i possibili asteroidi
killer allora facendo così in realtà si
sono scoperti tantissimi asteroidi ora
si sono sono conosciuti negli ultimi per
cui potete vedere gli ultimi 20 30 anni
sono scortati scoperti 600 mila
asteroidi in generale
almeno 600 mila di cui 17.000 sono
quelli che passano vicini alla terra
gli inglesi si chiamano neo ovvero
mirror's edge e jack passo vicino alla
terra e questi possono avere una certa
possibilità di avvicinarsi alla terra e
quindi di cadere sulla terra
ora una volta che abbiamo scoperto
questi asteroidi che passano vicino alla
terra
bisogna fare dei calcoli molto
complicati algoritmi molto complessi
allora attualmente al mondo ci sono due
gruppi che si occupano di questo tipo di
calcoli 1 il jpl della nasa e l'altro il
nostro gruppo proprio a pisa che è nato
all'università di pisa e adesso abbiamo
un po spostato al egizia situazione
europea e questo per dire che noi
abbiamo una leadership noi italiani
abbiamo una leadership non solo europea
ma mondiale
su questo tipo di attività anzi a dirla
tutta
nel 1999 siamo stati i primi ad averlo
fatto una volta che noi abbiamo
calcolato che c'è un oggetto con una
certa probabilità di impatto non basta
e importante che gli astronomi
continuano ad osservare questo possibile
impattato re non solo gli astronomi ma
anche gli astrofili gli astrofili sono
cittadini comuni come voi che con il tè
scoperte che possono avere a casa
dietro nel giardino possono osservarlo e
contribuire ad aumentare la mole di dati
e quindi sa per determinare con maggiore
accuratezza se l'asteroide cada o non
cadrà quindi il ruolo anche le persone
comuni questo questo contesto è molto
molto importante ritorno anche un'altra
cosa
l'italia e l'europa adesso stanno
facendo molto devono recuperare un po
alla strada fatta da degli americani
però già da dieci anni l'europa e
l'agenzia spaziale europea sta mettendo
delle forti risorse tant'è che da
qualche anno esiste un centro si chiama
neo coordinatore che si trova proprio a
frascati in italia grazie alla nostra
leadership in questo settore
detto ciò adesso vorrei fare un piccolo
annuncio perché nella mia carriera ha
avuto la fortuna anche di scoprire
diversi diverse decine di asteroidi e da
scopritore posso anche dare il nome a
all'asteroide e siccome sono legato a
questa città perché la città di mio
padre la famiglia di mio padre ma anche
la città dove ho vissuto durante il
periodo all'università quindi sono molto
legato
per contro contraccambia il mio affetto
io ho voluto dedicare opportuno degli
asteroidi che si chiama 78mila 661
proprio alla città di castelfranco
[Musica]
quindi volevo fare il filo finale del
discorso allora il pericolo come dicevo
degli asteroidi
esiste però è sotto controllo abbiamo
scoperto già il 90 per cento degli
asteroidi più grandi di un km sono
quelli potenzialmente pericolose per la
terra
quindi non dobbiamo preoccuparci la cosa
importante il messaggio che vi do anche
se voi vi siete interessare l'argomento
potete anche voi contribuire alla
salvezza del pianeta
bastano tre cose il telescopio tanta
passione e un piccolo esperienza grazie
[Applauso]